[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans l'enquête sur le double meurtre de
Flavin les gendarmes ont diffusé la
photographie du petit Martin le
nourrisson toujours porté disparu
une famille massacrée
un bébé introuvable
car c'est horrible une petite fille de
12 ans abattue d'une balle de la tête
une maman pareille vraiment du sang
énormément partout
un véritable casse-tête pour les
enquêteurs
c'est terrible de se dire voilà petit
bébé de 5 semaines qui est peut-être
entre des mains criminelles
[Musique]
il y a un contre-la-montre qui se joue
il faut venir au secours de cet enfant
le village était terrorisé parce que on
ne sait pas qui a fait ça on se dit
c'est peut-être un voisin tout c'est un
peu fou
on n'a pas compris
[Musique]
tout commence l'indicateur de février
2000 à Flavin dans l'Aveyron
en fin de matinée Patrice Moulinier un
frigoriste de 43 ans veut faire une
surprise à sa femme c'est le jour de la
Saint-Valentin il a décidé d'acheter des
orchidées pour sa femme Manuela
sur le chemin de la maison Patrice
Moulinier essaie d'appeler Manuela à
plusieurs reprises sans succès il a
quand même été intrigué que personne ne
répondait il a décidé de rentrer rentrer
à la maison voir ce qui se passait
il revient vers 11h50 à son domicile qui
est 2 rue Saint-Pierre à Flavin
pour lui faire la surprise
il l'appelle elle ne répond pas elle
n'est pas au rez-de-chaussée il monte à
l'étage
à ce moment-là Patrice Moulinier ne se
doute pas un instant de l'horreur à
laquelle il va être confronté il pousse
la porte de d'une chambre
et là il découvre un carnage
[Musique]
il trouve sa femme Manuela et sa fille à
Morgane morte il se précipite vers le
petit couffin puisqu'il a un bébé qui
s'appelle Martin qui a 5 semaines et là
il s'aperçoit que l'enfant a disparu
Patrice Moulinier était épouvanté il
sort de chez lui dans un état second fou
de douleur il criait partout dans la rue
il interpellait tout le monde il hurle
on a tué ma famille on a tué ma famille
il était dans tous ses états
hébété l'homme va chercher de l'aide au
restaurant situé à quelques mètres de
chez lui et il tente d'expliquer ce qui
lui arrive au patron des lieux
[Musique]
il est incohérent enfin on comprend pas
très bien ce qui raconte mais en tout
cas le patron du restaurant comprend
qu'il y a un problème par bride de mots
et il prévient les gendarmes
aussitôt les gendarmes de Rodez et de
Montpellier arrivent à Flavin
ils investissent la maison
et entre dans la chambre
on est pas resté longtemps quoi
parce que
c'est pas c'était pas beau à voir quoi
c'est d'abord une chambre avec deux
cadavres alors une dame 36 ans donc
Madame Molinier ensuite la une jeune
fille de 12 ans également avec beaucoup
de sang
Manuella Moulinier 36 ans et sa
belle-fille Morgan Moulinier 12 ans ont
été sauvagement abattus
suite on voit que la cause de la mort
est très nette c'est dans les deux cas
une balle dans la tête
de morts doublées d'une disparition car
le petit Martin âgé à peine 5 semaines
n'est plus dans son berceau
[Musique]
une disparition d'enfant
avec aucun élément de base donc pour
nous c'est le mort très très grave t'es
mort très très grave
les experts de la gendarmerie ratissent
la maison pour tenter de trouver des
indices matériels
et alors grande surprise il ne trouve
qu'aucune empreinte Baden aucune trace
du criminel un peu comme si elles
avaient été effacées
et puis il y a un détail qui intrigue
légendes il n'y a pas des fractions
c'est le premier point qui avait pas de
traces de vol puisqu'il y avait un
porte-monnaie qui contenait pas mal
d'argent liquide qui était resté là les
bijoux sont là et l'argent est là rien
n'a été volé
donc si vous voulez la porte du
cambrioleur est vite refermer
pour les enquêteurs il semble a priori
que les victimes connaissaient leur
tueur
une hypothèse confirmée par l'ordre
presque irréel qui règne dans toutes les
pièces car malgré la violence du crime
il n'y a aucune trace de lutte visible
dans la maison
présent lors de cette fouille Patrice
Molinier le père remarque pourtant qu'un
objet a disparu
la seule chose que Patrice Molinier a pu
préciser c'est que Martin a bien
évidemment avait disparu et qu'un sac de
voyage également avec disparu un bébé de
5 semaines kidnappait une mère et une
fille froidement abattue pas des
fractions et le vol d'un sac de voyage
les gendarmes le savent ils sont face à
une énigme qui s'annonce très difficile
à résoudre on sait pas où on va c'était
en fait un vide complet je n'avais nous
l'avions aucune information
un défaut d'indice les équipes de
gendarmerie débutent une enquête de
voisinage peut-être quelqu'un a-t-il vu
ou entendu quelque chose
[Musique]
on voit voir des témoins des témoins des
témoins qui immédiatement il y a une
vingtaine de gendarmes à qui on a
réparti la commune et qui vont frapper
aux portes interroger les gens qui
passent les commerçants voir le maire
etc
rien aucun signalement de personnes qui
qui ont été vu sortir de cette maison
aucun témoin des coups de feu puisqu'il
s'agissait d'un meurtre par arme à feu
aucune personne qui a été rien d'anormal
n'a été vu dans le dans le dans le
village
désormais l'urgence pour les enquêteurs
est de retrouver au plus vite le bébé de
5 semaines
on passe que peut-être il y a encore
envie et donc là il faut trouver
rapidement c'est la vie d'un enfant vous
comprenez un petit bébé de 5 semaines
c'est terrible de se dire voilà petit
bébé de 5 semaines qui est peut-être
entre des mains criminelles donc il est
urgent de le retrouver il prend un
biberon toutes les trois heures donc si
Martin il a pas été
soigné bien comme il faut il y a de
grandes chances qui qui dépérissent
assez vite
il y a un contre-la-montre qui se joue
il faut venir au secours de cet enfant
et qui est en péril qui est on imagine
on imagine danger une soixantaine
d'hommes et mobilisés
d'importants moyens sont déployés une
équipe cynophile des plongeurs un
hélicoptère toute la région est passée
au peigne fin
tout est vérifié sur les l'itinéraire
entre Flavin et Rodez les cours d'eau
l'Aveyron la rivière Aveyron et vérifier
des plongeurs sont appelés
viennent vérifier l'eau il y a des trous
là où il y a des jetés pour retenir
l'eau
le petit Martin est-il encore en vie
pour le savoir les gendarmes ne
négligent aucune piste tous les détritus
de l'agglomération de Rodez et ses
abords sont envoyés à des charges à 7h30
donc il est nos collègues sont allés
avec des bottes avec des treillis et des
fourches pour pour amener je sais pas
combien de tonnes pendant deux jours on
sait pas combien de temps de poubelles
de détritus
voir si on trouvait pas le cadavre de
Martin
ils vont regarder dans toutes les
poubelles qui sont inflamens ils vont
faire un travail de de fourmi assez
phénoménale mais malheureusement ils
vont pas retrouver le corps ni le bébé
ni le corps les heures passent les
chances de retrouver le petit Martin
vivant sa meuf
aucun témoin pas de trace de l'enfant
pour le moment l'enquête repose sur le
sol témoignage de Patrice Moulinier qui
serait la dernière personne à avoir vu
sa famille en vie
du coup une idée germe dans la tête des
enquêteurs
peut-il s'agir d'un crime passionnel
pour le savoir il se plonge dans la vie
du couple
avec Manuela ils sont amis d'enfance
Patrice a eu un parcours sentimental un
peu compliqué il a eu deux mariages
précédemment et puis la retrouver en
fait son ami d'enfance Manuela qu'il a
épousé donc en 98
Manuela est espagnol Patrice vient de la
Dordogne ils se sont installés dans
l'Aveyron quelques mois auparavant
alors le couple il y a peu de temps en
fait qui sont à Flavin lui donc il est
frigoriste à Rodez sa femme travaillait
dans un dans un restaurant comme
plongeuse je crois depuis peu ils
étaient en fin de compte très peu connu
du villageois c'était pas des gens ici
quoi
une voiture rouge un peu typée une Honda
une voiture un peu voiture de sport etc
donc il est ils sont remarqué mais sans
plus en tout cas ils sont pas du tout
perçus comme un couple à problèmes ou
comme comme des gens qui sont sans arrêt
en conflit ou quelque chose comme ça à
première vue rien ne laisse supposer une
quelconque tension dans ce couple à la
vie très ordinaire et très discrète
un peu trop peut-être
Patrice Moulinier aurait-il quelque
chose à cacher l'homme est emmené pour
être auditionné
et à la gendarmerie de Pont-de-Salars
Moulinier contre toute attente un
comportement très singulier
c'est un petit étonnement parce que j'ai
trouvé que Monsieur Moulinier était
étonnamment froid par rapport à
l'événement on m'avait décrit quelqu'un
qui était comme un fou quand il était
sorti de la maison
à gesticulé partout à crier on a tué ma
famille on a tué ma famille je suis
tombé sur une personne de relativement
calme pour pour le pour la scène qu'elle
avait vu elle en parle plus en premier
et jamais il s'insurge en disant moi
j'ai perdu de deux personnes je vous
vous m'accusez pourquoi vous recherchez
pas longtemps non il a toujours des
réponses des explications il paraît
assez froid d'ailleurs et ça peut-être
c'est je crois que j'ai eu 22 ans de
section de recherche c'est une des
personnes qui m'a assez déstabilisée sur
le plan il avait le comportement de
l'auteur
les enquêteurs ont d'autant plus de
doutes à l'égard de Patrice Moulinier
qu'en examinant ces allées et venus le
jour du drame il découvre une
incohérence dans son emploi du temps
il y avait des choses qui collaient pas
entre ce qu'il nous disaient et puis ce
que nous ce qu'on pouvait vérifier il y
a un trou dans son emploi du temps d'une
heure et demie ce lundi matin lundi 14
février 2000
je suis parti de chez moi entre 7h50 et
7h55 j'ai réparé la fuite sur le frigo
sur les coups de 11h j'ai été au petit
Leclerc pour jeter un coup d'œil sur les
installations
problème aucun témoin ne peut corroborer
cet emploi du temps
il est parti à 7h50 7h55 de chez lui il
a été à une vingtaine de kilomètres de
là faire quelques courses ensuite il a
fait l'entretien ça c'est son boulot de
de frigo
il y en a pour une heure à peu près et à
partir de là on sait plus très bien ce
qu'il fait jusqu'à 11h50 heure à
laquelle il va découvrir donc le carnage
le militaire je ne paraît pas
correspondre pourquoi vous êtes revenus
à la maison pourquoi il y a tout à
l'heure et telle heure on sait plus vous
êtes passé et chose incroyable le père
de famille est incapable d'apporter des
explications
manifestement Patrice Moulinier cache
quelque chose au gendarmes l'homme est
donc transféré à la gendarmerie de Rodez
et placée en garde à vue
le jour tombe sur Flavin 24 heures après
la découverte du drame le petit Martin
reste introuvable au village l'ambiance
étendue
le village était terrorisé parce que on
ne sait pas qui a fait ça on se dit
c'est peut-être un voisin du coup les
gens se barricadent dire rasent les murs
ils ont peur je suis passé la première
nuit à cet art dans la soirée et c'était
un village mort tout le monde était
enfermé chez soi absolument personne
dans la rue afin de rassurer la
population traumatisée par l'horreur du
crime commis les enquêteurs prennent une
décision inhabituelle
les gendarmes vont venir s'installer à
Flavin la mairie met à leur disposition
un local qui va leur permettre d'établir
leur QG comme ils sont une soixantaine
la présence de l'uniforme rassure un
petit peu le l'habitant
[Musique]
le lendemain mardi 15 février l'autopsie
permet aux enquêteurs de cerner un peu
plus le profil du meurtrier
le tueur agit de son froid sans hésiter
cela ressemble à une exécution en règle
les médecins légistes
indiquent que la mère a été abattue à
Boutou champ d'une balle de 22 long
rifle et quant à l'enfant Morgan elle a
été également abattue d'une balle de 22
long rifle dans la tête selon le médecin
légiste Manuela et Morgan ont été tués
entre 9h30 et 11h45
Manuela a été touché à l'arrière du
crâne ce qui signifie qu'elle a été tué
par surprise
[Musique]
pour Morgane Lafayette de 12 ans ses
différents le rapport d'autopsie donne
un détail particulièrement tragique la
seule éducation [ __ ] c'est que
visiblement Morgan malheureusement a vu
la mort puisque elle s'est protégé à sa
mère et un projectile lui a traversé la
main avant de se faire sa tête
à la lecture du rapport les enquêteurs
concluent que Morgane a tenté de se
protéger mais que le tueur extrêmement
déterminé n'a eu aucune hésitation
à la gendarmerie de Rodez Patrice
Moulinier continue de nier en bloc tout
implication dans ce double homicide
avez-vous quelque chose à nous déclarer
non je vous ai dit toute la vérité je
n'y suis pour rien je n'ai rien à me
reprocher
et pourtant les enquêteurs ne savent
toujours pas ce que le suspect a fait
avant 11h du matin à l'intérieur de la
gendarmerie il y a les groupes qui
commencent à penser sérieusement qui
pourraient être le coupable de scarnage
même s'il n'en saisissent pas le mobile
il ne trouve quand même curieux et il
l'est d'ailleurs franchement nous avons
nous lui avons carrément dit que c'était
lui qui avait tué sa famille
ça ne peut être que toi
alors pourquoi Patrice Moulinier
aurait-il tué sa femme
interrogé sur son passé l'homme révèle
peu à peu une autre facette de sa
personnalité c'est quelqu'un qui qui a
toujours couru un petit peu après les
femmes qui a eu beaucoup de conquêtes
qui qui s'est marié qui a aussi
semble-t-il
alors
participer à des
soirées un petit peu coquines enfin on
parle un petit peu de partout on parle
aussi de voilà c'est pas très c'est pas
très clair dans les informations que
l'on a à ce moment là mais bon on sent
bien que le garçon a voyagé quoi Patrice
Molinier avec quand même été marié deux
fois auparavant avant d'être de prendre
pour épouse Manuela Molinier est-ce
qu'il y avait pas une rancœur derrière
Patrice Molinier a-t-il changé depuis
qu'il s'est marié avec Manuela
est-il vraiment ce père de famille
tranquille dont il donne l'image l'homme
est interrogé sans relâche sa garde à
vue est prolongée
[Musique]
par ailleurs les recherches du petit
Martin le bébé de 5 semaines
s'intensifie
l'affaire prend une ampleur nationale
lorsqu'un appel à témoin est lancé
dans l'enquête sur le double meurtre de
Flavin les gendarmes ont diffusé la
photographie du petit Martin le
nourrisson toujours porté disparu la
photo du bébé introuvable a été diffusée
dans les maternités les hôpitaux le
nourrisson qui était allaité peut-il
être vivant et réapparaître plus tard
on a eu des appels une centaine d'appels
de partout en France
mais qui n'ont pas donné les résultats
que nous espérions
l'appel à témoins ne donne rien le bébé
est toujours introuvable
[Musique]
il est 19h à la gendarmerie de Rodez
Patrice Moulinier toujours en garde à
vue mais les enquêteurs s'interrogent
si l'homme qu'ils ont en face de et bien
l'auteur du massacre de sa famille
pourquoi a-t-il laissé le bébé de 5
semaines vivant
les gendarmes se demandent s'ils ne font
pas fausse route et c'est Patrice
Molinier lui-même qui va leur apporter
la réponse on lui a posé la question
est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui pourraient
avoir un désir de vengeance envers vous
ou envers votre famille et parmi ces
ce qu'il nous disait parmi tout ce qu'il
nous a dit il nous a cité quelqu'un qui
était qui nous a semblé curieux
il se souvient d'avoir reçu un coup de
téléphone d'un type qui s'appelle
Jean-Marie Von Matt
un type qui a été son voisin et son
copain pendant des années mais qu'il a
pas vu depuis 10 ou 15 ans
c'était un châtelain nous dit-il qui
élevé des chiens c'est d'ailleurs ça
l'objet de la rencontre je crois que
c'était rencontrés au cours d'une foire
ce monsieur vanmat l'invité dans son
château et puis se sont revus ensuite à
plusieurs reprises
la passion commune des deux hommes pour
les chiens les rapprochent
au fil du temps ils deviennent de très
bons amis
et votre Matt le riche châtelain c'est
se montrer très généreux
au point de faire un Moulinier un cadeau
pour le moins inhabituel
nous dit que visiblement
sa disposition donc c'était un accord en
clair bonne mat propose à son nouvel ami
une forme de ménage à trois
en audition moulini raconte qu'il allait
régulièrement au château retrouver
Simone avec la sentiment de son mari
[Musique]
cet accord aurait duré plusieurs années
jusqu'au déménagement
et Moulinier rajoute qu'il n'a pas vu le
Chatelain depuis 15 ans et n'avait plus
de contact ni avec lui ni avec sa femme
c'est pourquoi il a été très surpris de
son appel 3 semaines avant le drame
et voici ce que votre mat lui aurait
annoncé souvent moi qui est installé aux
États-Unis depuis 3 ans quelques années
m'a appelé pour apprendre le décès de
son épouse qui serait morte qui serait
décisive à la suite d'un avc
l'homme était en pleurs au téléphone
Patrice Moulinier
a essayé de le rassurer comme il a pu
l'autre lui a demandé comment il allait
qu'est-ce qu'il devenait et Patrice
Moulinier a répondu au malheur par le
bonheur si je puis dire c'est à dire que
l'un annonce la mort de sa femme et
l'autre annonce qu'il vient de se marier
et qu'il vient d'avoir un enfant
la conversation entre les deux hommes
semble a priori anodine seulement peu à
peu les propos devonat aurait pris une
étrange tournure
et l'enquête va plonger dans
l'irrationnel
à bord d'un sujet que Moulinier comprend
pas il lui parle d'impact qui aurait
autour de lui-même sa femme Moulinier et
il comprend pas ce dont votre mat veut
parler
il m'a dit qu'il fallait que je libère
son âme à elle par rapport à une
promesse que sa femme m'aurait faite
d'après votre mat lorsque Simone était
la maîtresse de Patrice Moulinier elle
lui aurait fait le serment de le
retrouver après sa mort
et ce n'est pas tout au cours de cet
appel téléphonique Jean-Marie vanmatt va
demander à mouligner de lui rendre un
service vos menthe vous voulez que
Moulinier se délit de ce de ce serment
il m'a demandé de la dégager de ce
serment j'ai bien sûr dit oui que
j'étais même pas au courant d'un tel
serment
il décrivait votre bat comme quelqu'un
qui était un petit peu mystique qui
avait pratiqué pas lesotérisme mais
il y avait des choses autour de lui on
sentait qu'il était des forces
supérieures des choses que que moulinet
comprenait pas bien parce que vous muni
c'est quelqu'un qui était une personne
simple
des choses comme elles viennent la
nature est ainsi etc et les enquêteurs
non plus ne sont pas bien sûr de tout
comprendre
que signifie réellement ce serment entre
Simone et Moulinier y a-t-il un lien
avec la mort de sa femme et de sa fille
ce von mat pourrait-il être responsable
de la disparition du bébé
c'est à une véritable énigme ésotérique
que sont confrontés légendaires et leur
enquête s'annonce d'autant plus
difficile que Jean-Marie van Matt a
déménagé il habite désormais à Miami à
des milliers de kilomètres de Flavin
faute de preuves Patrice Moulinier quant
à lui est remis en liberté
alors que les gendarmes s'apprêtent à
s'envoler pour Miami pour interroger
Jean-Marie van maths
un nouveau témoignage va venir relancer
toute l'enquête
des jeunes gens ont vu quelque chose le
jour du double meurtre
ils vont tomber sur un groupe de
collégiens qui
vont dire mais nous on a vu une voiture
une voiture
c'est une grosse voiture on croit que
c'était une BMV c'était drôle parce
qu'elle n'est pas les mêmes plate que
nous c'était pas les plaques françaises
donc ils ont ils ont bien repéré cette
voiture et d'autant plus que le
conducteur de la voiture s'est arrêté et
leur a demandé avec un accent très fort
où était la rue Saint-Pierre et
justement la rue Saint-Pierre c'est la
rue où Patrice Moulinier Emmanuel habité
mais qui est cet homme qui cherche de
bon matin la petite rue où vit la
famille Moulinier
un accent des plaques d'immatriculation
étrangères évidemment les gendarmes se
demandent immédiatement si l'homme à la
BMW ne serait pas Jean-Marie vannemane
ils vont donc chercher à savoir si par
hasard il ne serait pas revenu en France
récemment et le résultat est immédiat il
y a un
Jean-Marie vanmatt qui a voyagé sur un
Miami Zurich le 13 février 2000 il a
atterri à Zurich le 13 février 2000 la
veille du crime il y a donc bien un
certain von Mad qui est arrivé en Europe
par un vol en provenance de Miami la
coïncidence semble énorme
somme toute quelque chose chiffonnent
les gendarmes car Zurich est situé après
de 900 km de Flavin et donc deux
gendarmes sont allés en Suisse pour
essayer de voir avec nos camarades
suisses si il y avait quelque chose à
trouver et sur place les enquêteurs vont
faire le tour des agences de location de
voiture afin de vérifier si Jean-Marie
votre mat n'a pas loué une BMW sombre
et il s'avère que votre mat alloué une
voiture
[Musique]
qui était immatriculum Suisse qui était
de couleur noire mais qu'il n'était pas
une BMV en revanche c'est une Vectra
Opel Vectra qui peut éventuellement
ressembler à une DMP
l'enquête progresse bonne math fait doré
avant partie des suspects du massacre de
flaves
les gendarmes et c'est maintenant dans
sa voix un peu plus sur la vie de ce
riche marchand de bien de 52 ans à
l'origine c'est un mécanicien il est
dans l'automobile il semble faire
fortune dans l'immobilier en Suisse il a
des problèmes avec le fisc il est
expulsé de Suisse pour fraude fiscale
en 1981 Jean-Marie van maths se réfugie
en Dordogne où il achète ce château
accompagnac il s'installe avec sa femme
Simone et leurs trois enfants au village
vanmat est perçu comme un homme arrogant
qui en impose comme l'on dit voici
Michel Parisot il a racheté son château
en 1990 cette et se souvient bien de
Jean-Marie van Matt de prime abord c'est
un personnage excessivement mondain très
très élégant très très
solide très très carré très
hautain méprisant parfois
mais les enquêteurs découvrent que
derrière le personnage mondain et bourru
se cachant en réalité un misanthrope qui
vit presque reclus dans sa propriété
effectivement on a trouvé quelqu'un un
personnage un petit peu mystique qui
s'entendait qu'il y avait peu d'amis qui
s'entendaient avec peu de monde qui
était brutal dans ses relations sa mère
soit disant c'est une descendance de
Charlemagne
tout ça c'était un peu fabulé
et ce n'est pas tout outre ses
affabulations les gendarmes vont
découvrir que votre mat est un homme
violent voire paranoïaque
il jouait beaucoup avec le fusil
et menacé les gens un jour il m'a dit
mais qu'est-ce qui m'empêcherait de
mettre dans votre puits enfin dans le
puits qui m'apporte pas puis que c'est
le château était pas encore acheté de
mettre tout des batteries de voiture
dans le fond du puits et de polluer
complètement votre eau et de et de
couper toutes les toutes les
canalisations d'eau souterraines qui
servent à arroser le parc et c'est là
que je lui ai dit écoutez vous avez
vendu votre anne-mouttable c'est pas
possible vous pouvez pas vous pouvez pas
parler comme ça si vous êtes quelqu'un
avec qui on peut s'entendre pour le
moins le personnage de Jean-Marie van
Matt intrigue les enquêteurs
pour retrouver sa trace les gendarmes
n'ont d'autre choix que de se concentrer
sur le seul élément matériel dont il
dispose la berline noire qu'ils ont
retrouvé chez le loueur de voiture de
Zurich
[Musique]
ils vont fouiller cette cette voiture
cette Opel Vectra bien à fond avec des
yeux d'enquêteurs qui en veulent qui
veulent trouver
dans la moquette du plancher ils ont
retrouvé une balle de valdora rifle
plus
du sang des 13 décembre qui étaient
logés sous le tableau de bord
côté passager
lorsqu'on met les pieds on a toujours en
retour de tableau de bord comme ça et là
dessous ils ont retrouvé des phrases de
sang une balle de 22 Long rifles
exactement le même calibre que celui qui
a été utilisé pour abattre Manuela et
Morgane
la découverte est inespérée la balle est
immédiatement envoyée au laboratoire de
la gendarmerie le résultat ne fait que
confirmer les soupçons des enquêteurs
elle montrera d'une part que
elle a été tirée par la même arme que
celle qui a tué Morgane et Manuela et
d'autre part elle porte des petites
traces de sang qui se révèlent être du
sang du petit Martin donc on peut
imaginer que le petit Martin est mort à
ce moment-là et a été tué d'une balle
dans la voiture qui avait été loué par
par votre mat
le doute n'est plus permis Martin est
mort
certainement abattus dans la voiture et
probablement par Jean-Marie van Matt
reste maintenant à mettre la main sur
l'assassin
les enquêteurs vont donc tenter de
reconstituer l'emploi du temps du
suspect
d'après le loueur vonmat est parti le 13
février de Suisse il y a un peu moins de
900 km entre Zurich et Flavin il lui a
donc fallu la journée pour parcourir une
telle distance
une fois arrivé dans la région de Flavin
l'homme a dû descendre dans un hôtel
pour y passer la nuit avant de commettre
son crime le lendemain le 14 février
alors les enquêteurs vont faire le tour
de tous les établissements hôteliers de
l'Aveyron
et c'est à Rodez à 9 km seulement de
Flavin qu'ils vont faire une découverte
de taille
les gens vont retrouver en périphérie de
Rodez un hôtel ou un individu alloué une
chambre donc dans pour la nuit du 13 au
14 sous le nom de lightner
il s'avère que en ayant déjà travaillé
sur votre main
c'est à dire que c'était le nom de jeune
fille de son épouse pour nous ça ne fait
plus aucun doute votre mat est venu à
[Musique]
reste maintenant une question car il y a
quelque chose qui ne colle pas pourquoi
le compteur de la voiture de location de
Jean-Marie van Matt indique qu'il a
parcouru 2000 km
car pour faire l'aller-retour Zurich
Flavin il aurait dû afficher une
distance de 1700 km
lorsqu'on faisait le trajet Suisse
Flavin
on avait plus de 300 km en plus
donc
où aurait-il pu aller
les enquêteurs tentent de trouver une
réponse en essayant de se mettre à la
place de Jean-Marie van Malte
quand on est dans une enquête de fou il
faut raisonner un peu comme comme celui
qui est le qui est l'auteur donc on a
quitté le raisonnable et on essaye les
gendarmes en tout cas essaye de se
mettre dans la peau du tueur comme on
savait que
[Musique]
il aimait bien son château de son
château en Dordogne
on s'est dit qu'il était peut-être passé
là et quand il regarde sur une carte et
qui font le détour par le château pour
revenir à l'aéroport de Zurich et sa
collait pile
entre la Suisse Rodez
le château de Campagnac
et la Suisse
20 km après
pour en avoir le cœur net quinze jours
après le crime une douzaine de gendarmes
partant Dordogne perquisitionné dans
l'ancien château de Jean-Marie van Matt
[Musique]
les enquêteurs placent beaucoup d'espoir
dans cette fouille
mais ils vont vite s'apercevoir que leur
tâche est colossale
alors on arrive là-bas en fin
d'après-midi et on va directement au
château
quand on a vu le château surtout
l'étendue du parc
on s'est dit que c'était pas gagné ils
sont face à une bâtisse qui fait 80 une
pièce sur un territoire de 210 hectares
autant vous dire que c'est pas rien
quand même donc il va falloir faire une
perquisition on cherche le cadavre d'un
nouveau-né
sur 210 hectares
et les gendarmes vont bénéficier d'un
incroyable coup de chance
et là ils vont être aidés parce que la
chance quand même souri de temps en
temps aux enquêteurs ils vont être aidés
par le jardinier qui est elle jardinier
à l'époque de Jean-Marie van Matt par le
petit peu de Vannes
et savoir comment il était tout et dans
le château la propriété il avait un
droit particulier où il allait ah oui
oui je me rappelle il allait dans les
bois là-bas il allait très souvent
là-bas les gendarmes se rendent donc à
l'endroit indiqué par le jardinier
[Musique]
il y a une cavité
et que ça nous fait penser ça fait
penser à un four bon il y a descendre à
l'intérieur ils sont pas excessivement
vieille
autour
des granulés blancs
aucun doute il y a bien eu un feu dans
cette forêt
et là au milieu descendre les enquêteurs
découvrent les ultimes-éléments de
preuve qu'il cherchait on trouve une
balle de 22 long rifle le même calibre
que celui qui est utilisé pour lequel on
a déjà retrouvé trois balles et ils
l'ont trouvé également des petites
boucles en laiton là en cuivre qui font
penser à des boucles de sacs de sacs de
voyage
le sac de voyage qui justement avait été
dérobé le jour du drame dans la maison
des mouliniers
donc à partir de ces deux éléments ils
se disent bon ben voilà c'est là que ça
s'est passé
et en réalité le petit Martin a dû être
brûlé mort puisqu'il avait été tué par
balle dans la voiture de location il a
été brûlé très probant avec le sac ou
dans le sac
à cet endroit pourquoi Jean-Marie van
Matt est-il venu dans ce château qui ne
lui appartient même plus pour brûler le
cadavre du petit Martin
les prélèvements vont apporter un
élément de réponse aux enquêteurs
[Musique]
car autour descendre il y a un indice
pour le moins curieux
en plus des restes du sac il retrouvait
dans le foyer du gros sel
alors on dit que c'est pour purifier
dans les rites sorcellerie et moi je le
connais pas les rideaux sourcils mais
que ça peut purifier une âme tout ça un
peu fou
on n'a pas compris tout cela mais ça
montre bien que celui qui qui l'a fait
qui a rassemblé tous ces éléments qui a
provoqué qui a fait cela quelque part il
est un peu fou
[Musique]
à ce stade les gendarmes sont presque
sûrs que les cendres sont celles du
petit Martin mais seuls des analyses
scientifiques poussées permettront d'en
apporter la preuve absolue
[Musique]
le nourrisson a-t-il été sacrifié au
cours d'une cérémonie ésotérique
quel est le mobile de ce triple crime
pour le savoir il faut retrouver
Jean-Marie vanmatt c'est la priorité des
enquêteurs
et grâce au réseau des transports
aériens les gendarmes savent que leur
suspect est rentré chez lui à Miami le
17 février soit trois jours après le
triple meurtre de Flavin
[Musique]
on savait qu'il habitait à
rue Lincoln et Beach qu'il avait
plusieurs appartements que ces enfants
étaient toujours avec lui à Miami
pour partir de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique les enquêteurs attendent
les autorisations de la justice
américaine
alors pendant ce temps-là il place sur
écoute téléphonique la famille de
Jean-Marie vanne en Alsace et c'est en
écoutant les conversations entre ses
cousins éloignés qu'ils vont faire une
découverte surprenante sur des écoutes
téléphoniques connard on apprend que
votre mat est mort
on apprend que votre mat est mort et
qu'il se serait suicidé s'est suicidé
dans son appartement
immédiatement les gendarmes contactent
leurs homologues aux États-Unis
[Musique]
on a pris contact avec notre
un collègue policier à au consulat qui a
demandé aux policiers de bien-abeach de
ne toucher à rien que ce gars-là était
soupçonné d'avoir tué des gens en France
et que des enquêteurs allaient venir
rapidement le 24 mars 2000 les gendarmes
arrivent à Miami et il se dirige vers
l'appartement de Jean-Marie bonne matte
accompagné par la police de Miami Beach
notre
agent du FBI on est donc dans un très
bel immeuble à Miami face à la mer
[Musique]
les lieux sont restés tels que
Jean-Marie von matte les avait laissé
avant de se donner la mort pour rien
elle était absolument rien n'a été bougé
quoi c'était en l'état hormis le cadavre
et la légendaire vont tomber sur une
scène hallucinante un véritable mausolée
à la gloire de son épouse Simone décédé
tout ce qui était miroir ou porte
coulissante vitrée
était recouvert de linge de drap blanc
des photos partout
et sur les murs de son appartement il
n'y a que des photos de sa femme qui
foutent de leur mariage des photos de
leur vie commune tout les murs sont
couverts de photos de son épouse des
photos de Simone sur son lit d'hôpital
des photos de Simone décédées
impressionnant impressionnant il y a
toutes les phases de leur vie comme ça
posait sur les murs agrafés sur les murs
et puis il y a aussi des petits mots
Simon tu m'appartiennent il faut que ton
inspire revienne avec moi rejoins-moi
viens avec moi libère-moi
partout partout dans la salle à manger
un suicide mis en scène des mots
mystérieux en guise de testament ajoutez
à la présence de gros sel dans le feu et
le pacte mentionné par Moulinier les
enquêteurs doivent accepter les vidence
le mobile du triple meurtre serait
purement mystique
ça ne fait que confirmer
votre folie dans sa folie meurtrière
Jean-Marie von madman suicidé l'action
de la justice s'éteint il n'y aura donc
pas de procès pour répondre à la
question que tout le monde se pose
pourquoi votre math s'est-il attaqué à
la famille de Patrice Moulinier
malgré tout grâce aux éléments dont il
disposent les enquêteurs émettent une
hypothèse sur l'incroyable parcours du
meurtrier présumé
[Musique]
le 9 décembre 1999
Simone meurt à Miami d'un AVC
Jean-Marie van maths et dévasté par le
chagrin il n'est plus le même homme il
est tombé dans la folie totale qu'il
avait totalement changé
après déjà lavé de sa femme et le décès
quand un mois plus tard votre mat
appelle son vieil ami Moulinier ce
dernier lui apprend la naissance de son
fils Martin
votre mat lui qui vient de perdre son
épouse imagine alors dans un moment de
folie qu'elle s'est réincarnée dans le
corps du petit Martin incroyable
il avait un très très grand amour un
très fort amour pour sa femme votre
match je crois quand il a perdu sa dur
d'être terrible et ça a dû déclencher
les troubles terribles et
il voulait la retrouver au paradis et
dans son esprit je pense que
si sa femme se réincarne dans cet enfant
elle n'est pas au paradis elle se elle
est de nouveau sur terre et dans le dans
les misères de la terre
donc ça n'allait pas avec ce qu'il
imaginait pour sa vie éternelle alors
pour libérer l'âme de sa femme l'homme
aurait imaginé une solution radicale
sacrifiée le nourrisson
le 12 février
Jean-Marie van Matt décolle de Miami
pour atterrir à Zurich le lendemain
c'est-à-dire le 13 février il loue une
Opel Vectra
dans la nuit du 13 au 14 il dort dans un
hôtel en périphérie de Rodez
le 14 février bonne mat arrive à Flavin
il serait entré dans la maison des
moulins
puis Morgane avant d'emporter dans un
sac de voyage le petit Martin qu'il
pensait être la réincarnation de sa
femme des femmes le 15 très probablement
il arrive au château avec le corps du
petit Martin qu'il a tué dans la voiture
il va procéder à sacrémation à l'endroit
où il avait l'habitude de se recueillir
ou de réfléchir sur son sur son terrain
et en brûlant le corps du bébé von mat
aurait tenté de libérer l'âme de sa
femme
et c'est pourquoi il aurait disposé
autour des cendres du gros sel utilisé
dans les rites de sorcellerie pour
conjurer le mauvais sort
le 17 février van maths rentre chez lui
ami
un mois plus tard le 11 mars il se
suicide pour rejoindre sa femme au
paradis
en noir tout en noir chemise noire
pantalon noir il a mis sur le sol une
espèce de toile cirée noire également du
cache les miroirs où il met cette toile
cirée colle les photos de son épouse du
jour de son mariage au jour de sa mort
puis il se suicide d'une balle dans la
tête
6 mois sont passés nous sommes au mois
de septembre 2000 les enquêteurs se
rendent en Dordogne chez les parents de
Patrice Moulinier l'homme s'y est
réfugié depuis qu'il a été mis hors de
cause
on est parti voir Patrice lorsqu'on a eu
la certitude que les cendres qu'il y
avait à
Campagnac était les cendres de Martin on
lui a fait confectionner une petite
turne c'est c'est rien mais bon mais ça
n'a peut-être aidé aussi à faire son
deuil d'avoir la présence des cendres de
son fils
Patrice Moulinier et littéralement
bouleversé par cette nouvelle
les gendarmes eux se souviendront
longtemps de cette affaire aussi
abominable que hors norme
[Musique]